MARTIN LUTHER KING, JR., SOMEONE
WHO FOUGHT TO END HATE AND
EXPAND CIVIL RIGHTS, THE
PRESIDENT AND DEMOCRATS ARE
FACING THE DIFFICULT REALITY
THAT THEIR HOPES TO PASS
SWEEPING ELECTION REFORM BILLS
ARE ALL BUT DEAD.
ACTUALS THE SENATE WILL TAKE UP
THEIR LEGISLATION, BUT IT IS
EXPECTED TO FAIL WITHOUT THE
SUPPORT OF ANY REPUBLICANS, AND
THE REFUSAL BY TWO DEMOCRATIC
SENATORS TO CHANGE THE RULES OF
THE SENATE TO PASS THE BILL WITH
JUST 51 VOTES AS OPPOSED TO 60.
IT WILL BE A DEVASTATING BLOW
FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN'S AGENDA AND
ALSO HIS POLITICAL CAPITOL,
AFTER PRESIDENT BIDEN PUT THE
WEIGHT OF HIS OFFICE AND HIS
REPUTATION AS A UNIFIER BEHIND
THE RULES CHANGE, DELIVERING A
WITHERING SPEECH IN ATLANTA,
AIMED AT OPPONENTS OF ELECTION
REFORM, AND THE FILIBUSTER
CHANGE, AND GOING TO CAPITOL
HILL THURSDAY TO RALLY HIS PARTY
AND STILL FAILING TO CONVINCE
SENATORS KEIR SPIN SINEMA AND
JOE MANCHIN AS WELL AS PERHAPS
OTHER DEMOCRATIC SENATORS TO
WH
CHANGE THE FILIBUSTER RULES.
JOINING ME NOW SOMEONE FIGHTING
FOR ELECTION REFORM AND VOTING
RIGHTS HIS ENTIRE CAREER, JIM
CLYBURN, DEMOCRAT OF SOUTH
CAROLINA.
MAJORITY WHIP CLYBURN, THANKS
VERY MUCH FOR JOINING US.
BEFORE IT WE DIVE INTO THE
ISSUES, TOMORROW IS MARTIN
LUTHER KING W, JR., AREA.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THE LAST
PROMINENT CIVIL RIGHTS LEADERS
FROM THAT ERA?
>> THANK YOU.
I SPENT A LOT OF TIME YESTERDAY
THE ACTUAL BIRTHDAY REFLECTING
ON KING'S LETTER FROM THE
BIRMINGHAM CITY JAIL.
THAT LETTER I REREAD THE LETTER
EVERY YEAR AND I ALWAYS GET
SOMETHING OUT OF IT, THAT I
DIDN'T SEE THERE BEFORE.
AND I SPOKE WITH YESTERDAY
ORIGINAL ON THIS WHOLE QUESTION
OF WHY WE CAN'T WAIT.
ALL OF THESE QUESTIONS THAT CAME
LEFT WITH US.
HE SAID TO US IN THAT LETTER
SOMETHING THAT IS VERY, VERY I
WOULD CALL IT CONSEQUENTIAL
TODAY AND THAT IS THIS.
SILENCE IS CONSENT.
WE HAVE TOO MUCH SILENCE IN THE
STATES FOR WHAT'S GOING ON
AROUND US TODAY.
I REMEMBER CORPORATIONS STEPPING
UP WHEN GEORGIA WAS PASSING
THOSE DRACONIAN VOTER LAWS DOWN
THERE.
ALL OF A SUDDEN NOW, THEY HAVE
GONE SILENT, AND KING TOLD US IN
THAT LETTER THAT WE ARE GOING TO
BE MADE TO REPENT, NOT JUST FOR
THE VITRIOLIC WORDS AND DEEDS OF
BAD PEOPLE BUT FOR THE FALLEN
SILENCE OF GOOD PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHAT I WAS THINKING ABOUT
ALL YESTERDAY.
>> THAT'S INTERESTING, BECAUSE
HILLARY CLINTON TWEETED A FAMOUS
QUOTE FROM THAT LETTER, FROM THE
BIRMINGHAM JAIL, AND IT WAS
ABOUT THE WHITE MODERATE.
HILLARY CLINTON TWEETED "MARTIN
LUTHER KING, JR., SAID "I HAD
HOPED THAT THE WHITE MODERATE
WOULD UNDERSTAND THAT LAW AND
ORDER EXISTS FOR THE PURPOSES OF
ESTABLISHING JUSTICE AND THAT
WHEN THEY FAIL IN THIS PURPOSE,
THEY BECOME THE DANGEROUSLY
STRUCTURED DAMS THAT BLOCK THE
FLOW OF SOCIAL PROGRESS."
THEN HILLARY CLINTON ADDED "THIS
IS A SUBTWEET."
A SUBTWEET IS WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT SOMETHING WITHOUT
NAMING THEM, PRESUMABLY
SECRETARY CLINTON WAS TALKING
ABOUT SENATORS JOE MADGEIN AND
KYRSTEN SINEMA.
AS YOU KNOW, MUCH OF THAT LETTER
IS ABOUT HOW ALLIES OF THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT COULD BE MORE
PROBLEMATIC THAN ENEMIES OF THE
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT, THE WHITE
MODERATE.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT
COMPARISON AND IS THAT WHAT'S
HAPPENING TODAY IN THE U.S.
SENATE?
>> I DO BELIEVE, AGREE WITH
THAT.
TODAY IS SUNDAY.
REMEMBER, KING WAS SITTING IN
JAIL, HE RECEIVED A LETTER FROM
EIGHT WHITE CLERGYMEN WHO WROTE
HIM ABOUT THEIR CONCERN.
THEY ASKED HIM TO LEAVE
BIRMINGHAM, AND THEY SAID THAT
THEY THOUGHT HIS CAUSE WAS
RIGHT, BUT HIS TIMING WAS WRONG
AND KING SAID TO THEM, TIME IS
NEUTRAL.
TIME CAN EITHER BE USED
DESTRUCTIVELY OR CONSTRUCTIVELY,
AND THAT'S WHEN HE SAID THAT HE
WAS COMING TO THE CONCLUSION
THAT THE PEOPLE OF ILL WILL IN
OUR SOCIETY WERE MAKING A MUCH
BETTER USE OF TIME THAN THE
PEOPLE OF GOODWILL, SO I WOULD
SAY THAT TO MY FRIENDS IN THE
SENATE NOW, PEOPLE OF ILL WILL
DEMONSTRATED HOW EFFECTIVE THEY
CAN USE THEIR TIME.
ARE WE GOING TO STEP UP, THE
PEOPLE OF GOODWILL AND USE OUR
TIME MORE EFFECTIVELY?
THAT LETTER, YOU KNOW, I ALWAYS
SAY, JAKE, THAT ASIDE FROM THE
BIBLE, I DO BELIEVE THAT LETTER
MAY BE THE MOST FINEST DOCUMENT
I'VE EVER READ.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN WENT TO
GEORGIA THIS WEEK TO PUSH FOR
SINEMA AND MANCHIN AND OTHERS TO
GET RID OF THE FILIBUSTER IN
ORDER TO PASS THESE TWO ELECTION
REFORM BILLS, AND THE PRESIDENT
ASKED THIS QUESTION, "DO YOU
WANT TO BE ON THE SIDE OF
ABRAHAM LINCOLN OR JEFFERSON
DAVIS?"
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO DEMOCRATS WHO
SAY THAT THAT WENT TOO FAR TO
COMPARE SOMEBODY WHO OPPOSES
CHANGING THE FILIBUSTER WITH A
TRAITOR WHO FOUGHT A WAR FOR
SLAVERY?
>> I WOULD ASK THOSE PEOPLE,
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS GOING TOO
FAR?
IS IT GOING TOO FAR TO
CRIMINALIZE, GIVING SOMEBODY A
BOTTLE OF WATER, STANDING IN
LINE TRYING TO VOTE, STANDING IN
LINE FOR FOUR OR FIVE HOURS, IS
THAT GOING TOO FAR?
IS IT GOING TOO FAR TO PUT IN
PLACE MECHANISMS TO NULLIFY A
VOTE WHEN PEOPLE CAST THEIR
VOTES IF YOU DON'T LIKE THE
OUTCOME, THEN YOU'VE GOT TO
NOTIFY THAT, IS THAT GOING TOO
FAR?
EVERYTHING WE'VE SEEN COMING OUT
OF GEORGIA VIOLATES THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA, AND ALEXANDER
HAMILTON TOLD US IN FEDERALIST
STATEMENT NUMBER 59 THAT WE
CANNOT LEAVE FEDERAL ELECTIONS
AND THEIR RESULTS UP TO STATES.
YOU HAVE 50 APPLICATIONS OF WHAT
THE LAW IS.
SO THAT IS WHAT'S GOING TOO FAR.
SO IF ANYBODY'S GOING TO FOCUS
ON THE SPEECH AND PAY NO
ATTENTION TO THE ACTIONS, THAT
VIOLATES THIS DIFFICULT PURPOSE.
IT'S THEIR DEEDS THAT REALLY
MATTER, NOT THE WORDS.
FOR US TO FOCUS ON THE
PRESIDENT'S WORDS AND NOT PAY
ANY ATTENTION TO THE DEEDS OF
THOSE LEGISLATORS IN TEXAS, IN
GEORGIA AND 17 OTHER STATES THAT
PASSED 35, 34 LAWS THAT ARE
DRACONIAN WHEN IT COMES TO
VOTING, THAT'S WHERE OUR
ATTENTION OUGHT TO BE.
>> NOW, DEMOCRAT SENATORS JOE
MANCHIN AND KYRSTEN SINEMA BOTH
SUPPORT THE TWO ELECTION REFORM
LEGISLATION BILLS.
THEY JUST SAY THEY OPPOSE
SIDE-STEPPING THE FILIBUSTER.
I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO WHAT
SENATOR SINEMA SAID DURING HER
FLOOR SPEECH THIS WEEK.
>> ELIMINATING THE 06-VOTE FLESH
HOLD WILL SIMPLY GUARANTEE THAT
WE LOSE A CRITICAL TOOL THAT WE
NEED TO SAFEGUARD OUR DEMOCRACY
FROM THREATS IN THE YEARS TO
COME.
>> HER BASIC ARGUMENT IS THAT
REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO TAKE
OVER THE CHAMBER AT SOME POINT,
AND DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO NEED
THAT FILIBUSTER.
JUST LAST NIGHT, DONALD TRUMP
CALLED FOR REPUBLICANS TO PASS
STRICTER LAWS WHEN IT CAME TO
THE ELECTION, VOTER I.D.
RESTRICTIONS, TO BAN DROP BOXES,
STOP NO EXCUSE ABSENTEE VOTING.
DOESN'T SHE HAVE A POINT, THE
DEMOCRATS MIGHT NEED THAT
FILIBUSTER AS SOON AS 2025 TO
STOP REPUBLICANS FROM IMPOSING
EVEN HARSHER VOTING
RESTRICTIONS?
>> LOOK, NO, SHE IS NOT RIGHT
ABOUT THAN.
WE JUST GOT AROUND THE FILL
BUSTER TO RAISE THE DEBT LIMIT.
WHY?
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO PUT THE
FULL FAITH AND CREDIT OF THE
UNITED STATES AT RISK.
NO ONE HAS ASKED HER TO
ELIMINATE THE FILIBUSTER.
THE FILIBUSTER IS THERE FOR ALL
OF THESE ISSUES THAT MAY BE
POLICY ISSUES, BUT WHEN IT COMES
TO THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA, NO ONE
PERSON SITTING DOWNTOWN IN THE
SPA OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO PICK UP
THE FORM AND SAY YOU ARE GOING
TO PUT A HOLD ON MY ABILITY TO
VOTE.
I WISH THEY'D STOP THAT
FOOLISHNESS BECAUSE IF WE DO NOT
PROTECT THE VOTE WITH EVERYTHING
THAT WE'VE GOT, WE WILL NOT HAVE
A COUNTRY TO PROTECT GOING
FORWARD.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE WE GOT THE
NOTION FROM, THAT THIS DEMOCRACY
IS HERE TO STAY NO MATTER HOW WE
CONDUCT OURSELVES.
OUR JOB WE TOOK THE OATH OF
OFFICE TO PROTECT THIS COUNTRY
FROM ALL ENEMIES, FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC.
THERE ARE DOMESTIC ENEMIES THAT
SHOWED UP JANUARY 6th AND THEY
DIDN'T STOP THERE.
THEY'RE STILL GOING ON AND YOU
HEAR IT WHEN THE PRESIDENT
TWEETS OUT OR WHATEVER HE SAID
ABOUT GETTING RID OF PEOPLE'S
CONVENIENT VOTING PLACES, SAYING
TO PARAPLEGICS THAT WE CAN'T
MAKE IT CONVENIENT FOR TO YOU
VOTE, SAYING TO 90-YEAR-OLD YOU
GOT TO STAND IN LINE FOUR AND
FIVE HOURS TO VOTE, AND IF
ANYBODY GIVES YOU A GLASS OF
WATER, THEY WILL BE PUT IN JAIL.
THAT'S THIRD WORLD STUFF.
>> CONGRESSMAN RUBEN GALLEGO IN
IS NOT RULING OUT A RUN IN 2024.
DO YOU THINK SENATOR SINEMA
SHOULD FACE A PRIMARY CHALLENGE?
>> I'LL STAY OUT OF THAT.RUBEN.
WE WORKED CLOSELY ON THESE
ISSUES IN HOTHE HOUSE AND HIS
RE-ELECTION, HE HASN'T SAID TO
ME HE IS GOING TO RUN FOR THE
UNITED STATES SENATE.
I'VE BEEN SUPPORTING HIM FOR
RE-ELECTION TO THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES BUT WE'LL SEE
WHAT HAPPENS.
HE'S A GOOD GUY.
>> QUICKLY, BEFORE WE GO, SIR,
ARE THE ELECTION REFORM BILLS
TED, DO YOU THINK?
>> NO, I DON'T.
THEY MAY BE ON LIFE SUPPORT BUT
YOU KNOW, JOHN LEWIS AND OTHERS
DID NOT GIVE UP AFTER THE '64
CIVIL RIGHTS ACT.
THAT'S WHY HE GOT THE '65 VOTING
RIGHTS ACT.
I WANT TO TELL EVERYBODY, WE'RE
NOT GIVING UP.
WE'RE GOING TO FIGHT, AND WE
PLAN